good evening ladies and gentlemen I'm
Rodney Phillips the curator of the Berg
collection of English and American
literature here at the library and
tonight it's my pleasure to introduce
Martin Amos who will very luckily for us
be speaking on Lolita in our series in
the forum my name is was born in Oxford
where he also in 1971 earned a degree
with honors and in his words wrote
malarial pageant like all nights essays
and was quote a relative late comer to
literature can't write pilgrim on the
path toward its discovery however once
discovered Mr Amos has obviously lost no
time and is now a total rebel Aryan
literature both writing it and writing
about it interestingly enough there's a
series of standard reference works
called the world authors series that we
keep in the burgh collection in many
libraries and from the dust jacket of
one of the most recent volumes smiles
and I think that's the word as the very
emblem of the contemporary one young
Martin Amos who in fact follows nicely
if that's a word you could use for him
in the line of his literary heroes
Nabokov and Bello like both of them he
is a master of both the darkness and the
comic a masterful satirist of his own
work he has said looked at seriously of
course my books are ghastly but the
point is they are satire I don't see
myself as a prophet I'm not writing
social comment my books are playful
literature I'm after laughs Martin the
Amos is the author of nine novels
including the Rachel papers dead babies
success other people the mystery story
money a suicide note London Fields time
x arrow the information and most lately
night train' he's also published a
volume of short stories entitled
Einsteins monsters one book about
videogames and two volumes of essays
before I introduce and I will he will
take place
Asians after the the lecture and there
are microphones on either side there if
you could step up to those to take a few
questions mr. amos lives in london but
nevertheless writes a lot about america
please help me welcome him tonight
good evening thank you very much for
coming
evidently the film of Lolita is not
something we're going to be able to see
in this country and I'll bring this this
will no doubt come up in the Q&A
conceivably it is a moral film because
the book is certainly a moral book and
that is my contention like the sweat of
lust and guilt the sweat of death
trickles through Lolita I wonder how
many readers survived the novel without
realizing that it's heroine is so to
speak dead on arrival like her child
their brief obituaries are tucked away
in the editors forward in nonchalant
school newsletter forum Mona doll as a
student in Paris Rita has recently
married the proprietor of a hotel in
Florida mrs. Richard F Schiller which is
Lolita died in childbed giving birth to
a stillborn girl on Christmas Day 1952
in gray star a settlement in the
remotest northwest vivian darkbloom has
written a biography etc etc then went
once the book begins Humberts childhood
love Annabel dies at 13 typhus and his
first wife Valyria dies also in
childbirth and his second wife Charlotte
dies quote a bad accident quote unquote
though of course this death is
structural and Charlotte's friend Jean
Philo dies at 33 cancer and the Lita's
young seduced seducer Charlie Holmes
dies career and her own seducer
quilty dies murder another structural
exit and then Humbert dies coronary
thrombosis and then the leader dies and
her daughter dies in a sense Lolita is
too great for its own good
it rushes up on the reader like a
recreational drug more powerful than any
yet discovered or devised in common with
its narrator it is both irresistible and
unforgivable
and yet it all works out I shall point
the way to what I take to be is livid
and juddering heart which is itself in
pre thrombotic turmoil or heaves and
lifts and thrills without aping the
expertise that style of neither costs
famous lectures without producing height
charts roadmaps no tell book matches and
so on it might still be as well to
establish what actually happens in
lolita morally how bad is all this on
paper anyway although he distances
distances himself with customary quarter
from the world of quote coal sheds and
alleyways of panting maniacs and howling
policemen Humbert Humbert is without
question and honest-to-god open-and-shut
sexual deviant displaying classic
ruthlessness guile and above all
attention to detail he parks the car at
the gates of school yards for instance
and obliges Lowe to fondle him as the
children emerge $0.65 secures similar
caress in her classroom while Humbert
admires a platinum classmate fellatio
prices peak at four dollars a session
before Humbert Humbert brings rates down
quote drastically by having her earn the
hard and nausea zwei commissioned to
participate in the school's theatrical
program unquote on the other hand he
performs complimentary cunnilingus when
his stepdaughter is laid low by fever
quote I could not resist the exquisite
can erisa tea of unexpected delights
venus fabric.you Llosa
though it was a very languid lolita that
moaned and coughed and shivered in my
embrace Humbert the son evidently
something of a bourgeois sadist with his
first wife Valyria he fantasized about
quote slapping her breasts out of
alignment or quote putting on his
mountain boots and taking a running kick
at her rump but in reality confined
himself to quote twisting fat fillet
brittle wrist the one she had fallen
upon fallen upon from a bicycle and
saying look here you fat fool same Ikeda
seed the weakened wrist is good sadists
know all about weak spots Humbert
strikes Lolita only once a tremendous
backhand cut during a jealous rage
otherwise making do with bribes bullying
and three main threats the rural rural
fastness the orphanage and the
reformatory quote in plainer words if we
two are found out you will be analyzed
and institutionalized my pet say to you
will dwell my Lolita will dwell come
here my brown flower with 39 other dopes
in a dirty dormitory no allow me please
under the supervision hideous matrons
this is the situation this is the choice
don't you think that under the
circumstances Dolores haze that is stick
to her oh man it is true that Humbert
goes on to commit murder he kills his
rival Clare quilty and despite its awful
comedy and despite quilt he's
worthlessness both as playwright and
citizen the deed is not denied its
primal colorations quilty is Humberts
brother after all his secret sharer
don't they have the same taste in
wordplay and women don't they have the
same voice drop that pistol he tells hum
but you will only wound me hideously and
then rot in jail will i recuperate in a
tropical setting cruelty is a heartless
jeepers and voyeur
one of the pornographers of real life
most readers I think would have sent to
the Justice of Humberts last page
verdict for reasons that may appear more
obvious than they really are I am
opposed to capital punishment had I come
before myself I would have given Humbert
at least 35 years for rape and dismissed
the rest of the charges unquote quill
tease death is not tragic
nor is Humberts fate nor is Lolita
the novel but Lolita herself is tragic
in her compacted span if tragedy
explores forted energy and possibility
then the liter is tragic is flatly
tragic and their mystery remains
how did Nabokov accommodate her story to
this 300 page blue streak to something
so embarrassingly funny
so unstoppably inspired so impossibly
racy literature has been as has been
pointed out is not life it is certainly
not public knife there is no character
issue it may be a nice bonus to know
that Nabokov was a kind man the
biographical paraphernalia tells us as
much actually everything he wrote tells
us as much Lolita
tells us as much this is not a
straightforward matter Lolita is a cruel
book about cruelty it is kind in the
sense that your enemy's enemy is your
friend no matter how daunting his aspect
as a critic Nabokov was more than
averagely sensitive to literary cruelty
though those of us who toil through
Cervantes I suspect after initial joked
chortling Lea habituate ourselves to the
infinite drubbing x' meted out and
sustained by the gaunt Hidalgo in his
lectures on Don quick slit however
Nabokov can barely bring himself to
contemplate the automatic could
thumbscrew enormities of this cruel and
crude Oberg quote the author seems to
Planet thus come with me on gentle
reader who enjoys seeing a live dog
inflated and kicked around like a soccer
football reader who likes of a Sunday
morning on his way to or from church to
poke his stick or direct his spittle at
a poor rogue in the stocks come I hope
you will be amused at what I have to
offer nevertheless Nabokov is the
laureate of cruelty cruelty hardly
exists elsewhere all the Lovelace's and
Osmonds turnout are not very much closer
in spell
to be mere hooligans and tyrants when
compared to Humbert Humbert to Herman
Herman his significant precursor in
despair to Rex and Margo in laughter in
the dark to Martha in king/queen knave
Nabokov understood cruelty he was wise
to it he knew it special intonation as
in this expert cadence from laughter in
the dark we're after
after the nicely poised skillfully the
rest of the sentence collapses into the
cruel everyday you may kiss me she
sobbed but not that way please the youth
shrugged his shoulders she returned home
on foot her brother otto who had seen
her go off thumped his fist down on her
neck and then kicked her skillfully so
that she fell and bruised herself
against the sewing machine now Humbert
is of course very cruel to Lolita not
just in the ruthless sandy crane known
as subjugation nor yet his sighing
intention of quote somehow on Kirk
getting rid of her with her brief
optimum has elapsed nor yet in his
fastidious observation of signs of wear
in his frigid and aging mistress Humbert
is surpassingly cruel in using Lolita
for the play of his wit and the play of
his prose his prose which sometimes
resembles the quote sweat-drenched
finery unquote that quote a brute of
forty unquote may casually and legally
shared in both hemispheres as a
scandalized Humbert notes before
thrusting quote himself up to the hilt
into his youthful bride unquote morally
the novel is all ricochet or rebound
however cruel Humbert is to Lolita
Nabokov is crueler to Humbert finessing
Lea cruel we all share the narrator's
smirk when he begins the sexual bribes
chapter with the following sentence
I'm now faced with a distasteful task of
recording a definite drop in Alito's
morals
the Wender smirk congeals we are left
staring at the moral heap that Humbert
has become underneath his arched eyebrow
irresistible and unforgivable it is
complicated and unreal
this is how it works Lolita herself is
such an anthology piece by now that even
non readers of the novel can close their
eyes and see her on the tennis court or
in the swimming pool or curled up in the
car car seat or the motel twin bed with
her ridiculous comics we tend to forget
that this blinding creation remains just
that a creation at a creation of Humbert
Humberts we have only Humberts word for
her and whatever it is that is wrong
with Humbert not even his short-lived
mother quote picnic picnic lightning
unquote the claim that her son was
playing with a full deck actually his
personal pack may comprise the fill full
52 but it is crammed with jokers and
wildcards tipless uses three eyed Queens
a reliable narrator in the strict sense
Humbert is not otherwise reliable and
let us remember that Nabokov was capable
capable of writing entire fictions to
spare the eye tail fire in which the
narrator narrators have no idea what is
going on at all Lolita I believe has
been partly isolated and distorted by
its celebrity quote the greatest novel
of rapture in modern fiction unquote
states the cover of the first penguin
which also informs us on the back that
Humbert is English
haven't we been conditioned to feel that
the Lita is Sooey generous a black sheep
a bit of tasteful indeed beautiful
erotica that Nabokov himself with this
particular novel somehow got carried
away great writers however never get
carried away even pretty average writers
never get carried away
people who write one novel and then go
back to journalism or accountancy they
get carried away Lolita is moral steer
than rapturous as all writing is and I
have come to see it with increasing or
as exactly the kind of novel that its
predecessors are pointing towards it
constructs a mind in the way that a
prose browning might have gone about it
through rigorous dramatic monologue
perhaps Lolita herself that leads to
begin with is a sadder traitor and more
ordinary being than Humbert Humbert is
willing or able to fix resembling the
quote decidedly homely cape kid unquote
that her mocked mother sees it maybe the
Lolita so identified with the geography
of the United States which has story
puts into motion is to some degree an
exiled delirious invention she is more
than a figment she is more than Don
quicks its Dulcinea but she is also an
externalization of Humberts glittering
quiddity Humbert is a narcissist one
hesitates to explore the psychological
connections if any between narcissism
and classical pedophilia and Freud must
been some good one suspects to the devil
the great Natick off so yet both
conditions are clearly regressive or
anorexic showing a reluctance to abandon
the sentimentally scaled-down perfection
of youth quote rope skipping hopscotch
ah leave me alone moans Humbert in my
pubescent Park in my mossy garden let
them play around me forever
grow up unquote even earlier in the
novel when recalling his child love
Annabel Humbert describes a last
snapshot of their group Annabel quote
did not come out well unquote she was
bending over her drink but I enthuses
Humbert sitting somewhat apart from the
rest came out with a kind of dramatic
conspicuousness a moody beetle-browed
boy in a dark sports shirt and well
tailored white shorts his legs crossed
sitting in profile looking away dramatic
moody well-tailored looking away now
that is the gist of romance the path of
self-love is always a rocky one but the
love shared by Humbert and Humbert for
all its rough and smooth is unquestioned
questionably the real thing no narrator
in literature I think goes on about his
physical splendor as passionately and
comically as the narrator of the liter
with his quote striking if somewhat
brutal good looks
unquote the younger paris-based Humbert
knew all too well that he could obtain
the snap of his fingers the choice of
the quote many crazed beauties who lash
his grimrock quote let me repeat with
quiet force I was and still am to split
despite me malar and exceptionally
handsome male slow-moving
tall with soft dark hair and a gloomy
that all the most seductive cast of
demeanor except exceptional virility
often etc etc when he first encounters
Lolita Humbert cruises past her and what
he feels to be his quote adult disguise
a great big handsome hunk of Movieland
manhood I have all the characteristics
he goes on to expound which according to
writers on the sex interests of children
start the response is stirring in a
little girl clean-cut jaw
muscular hand deep sonorous voice broad
shoulder moreover I am said to resemble
some
crooner or actor chap on whom lo has a
crush a few pages on he wonders if he
might quickly avail himself of a movie
land pinch quote a modern child an avid
reader movie magazines an expert in
dream slow close-ups might not think it
too strange I guessed if a handsome
intensity veera grown-up friend today
unquote very soon Humbert is trying on a
new pair of bathing trunks before the
mirror and Duty becomes he is married
the mother by now groped a bronzed
glamour boy unquote at hourglass Lake
about a third of the way through the
novel with Humberts corny gorgeousness
now massively established navagrahas
Humbert say with inimitable tentative
tentativeness quote I do not know if in
these tragic notes I have sufficiently
stressed the peculiar sending effect
that the writers good-looks
pseudo Celtic attractively simian
boyishly Manley had on women of every
age and environment of course such
announcements made in the first person
may sound ridiculous but every once in a
while I have to remind the reader of my
appearance much as a professional
novelist who has given a character of
his some mannerism or a dog has to go on
producing that dog or that mannerism
every time the character crops up there
may be more to it in the present case my
gloomy good looks should be kept in the
mind's eye if my story is to be properly
understood pubescent lo spoon to
Humberts charm as she did - hiccup II
music hiccup II more than adequately
summons the tonsil swallowing vocalists
of the period those throbbin sob idols
of the teens greenmail pantheon where as
Humbert later reminds Lolita
he was once privileged to stroll in his
afterward where when avakov speaks of
the exhilarations of quote Philistine
vulgarity unquote
he doesn't just mean Lolita or motels or
Amerika quote there is no intrinsic
difference between tally arctic and knee
arctic manners ie between old and new
worlds any proletarian from Chicago can
be as bourgeois in the flow variance
sense as a Duke Humbert with his quote
pleasantly arched thick black ad
eyebrows unquote as pictures pray well
for low quote it was to whom lo it was
to whom ads were dedicated the ideal
consumer the subject and object leathery
fowl poster like the poster gum to the
wall above lalita's bed quote a
full-page ad it represented a
dark-haired young husband lo had drawn a
jocose arrow to the Haggard lover's face
and had put in block letters H H the
resemblance Humbert allows was striking
quote first time I've seen a man wearing
a smoky jacket sir says the queerly
observant schoolmate of Lowe's except in
movies of course no doubt the low hum
story would have worked out wonderfully
in Hollywood in dreamworld or ad land
but this is only America cart car tool
and lawn sprinkler America and hum his
low stepfather three times her age and
for two years he rapes her at least
twice a day indeed Humbert situation is
fantastically contorted and extreme it
is the central miracle of the novel that
the tiny madman in his tiny cell becomes
artistically by a series of radical
shifts in context a Lord of infinite
space in bald structure Lolita is a tale
of chronic molestation
not the most liberating of narrative
schemes one can see why certain
publishers wanted Natick off to refit
the novel to a setting of appropriate
grimness and deracinated from the
authors afterward but one reader
suggested one publishers reader
suggested that his firm might consider
publication if I turn my Lolita into a
twelve-year-old lad and had him seduced
by Humbert a farmer in a barn amidst
gaunt and arid surroundings all this set
forth in strong realistic sentences
because in example he act crazy we all
act crazy I guess I guess God acts crazy
as it happens Nabokov finds a nun
covenant freedom in Humberts dark
confinement and writes with the
freshness of discovery about Parenthood
marriage jealousy America art and love
the angled is a tortured squint but the
vistas are large parents and guardians
of twelve-year-old girls will have
noticed that their wards have a tendency
to be difficult they may take Humberts
word for it that things are much more
difficult or in fact entirely impossible
when your 12 year old girl is also your
12 year old girlfriend the next time you
go out with your daughter imagine you
are going out with your daughter we know
that we know that limits and rules apply
in the matter of parental caresses that
quote girlish games of fluid or at least
two childishly fluid for the senior
partner to grasp unquote but the
ambitious molester had better learn the
ropes and quick if his charge is not
quote to start back in revulsion and
terror all but the childless will not
inquire sympathy when Humbert talks
aloes quote fits of disorganized boredom
intense and vehement griping a sprawling
droopy dopey eyed style and what is
called goofing off a kind of diffused
clowning how about this there was the
day when having withdrawn the functional
promise I had made her on the eve
whatever she had set her funny little
heart on a roller rink with some special
plastic floor or a movie matinee tip to
which she wanted to go alone I happened
to glimpse from the bathroom through a
chance combination of mirror a slant and
door ajar
on her face that look I cannot exactly
describe an expression of helplessness
so perfect that it seemed to grade into
one of rather comfortable inanity just
because this was the very limit of
injustice and frustration and every
limit presupposes something beyond it
comfortable inanity very good and
because of navicomp nerve and
truthfulness and because the artistic
opposite of cruelty is not kindness but
vulnerability the Lita's innocence is
never more piercingly evokes than during
the fateful night at the enchanted
hunters when the lightly drugged low
sits up in bed staring staring at me and
and thickly calling me Barbara when she
frees herself from the shadow of my
embrace doing this not consciously not
violently not with any personal distaste
but with the neutral plaintive murmur
the child demanding its natural rest or
when having been given water quote with
an infantile gesture that carried more
charm than any carnal caress little
Lolita wiped her lips against my
shoulder
similarly every father feels a pang when
his daughter begins to take a healthy
interest in the opposite sex but how
much more incandescent the pain this is
Freud made real when the daughter's
suitors are the father's rivals again
there is great comic veracity in the
horror and fastidiousness with which
Humbert views the repulsive Gale air of
the Lita's admirers goons in luxurious
cars maroon morons near blood pools
golden haired highschool uglies all
mussels and gonorrhea
odious visions of stinking highschool
buyers and sweatshirts and an n/bar red
cheek pressed against hers indeed every
variety of gangling reeking adolescent
quote from the perspiring nincompoop
whom holding hands thrill to the
self-sufficient rapist with pustules and
a souped-up car and when the rival is
quilty an adult a brother who physically
resembles a cousin of Humbert Humberts
and when the admiration is required by
the quite quote vile and beloved [ __ ]
unquote then the prose congest with a
lyrical disgust this is this disgust is
authentic because it is ultimately self
directed at the swimming pool quote
there he stood in the camouflage of sun
and shade disfigured by them and masked
by his own nakedness his damp black hair
glued to his round head his little
moustache a humid smear the wool on his
chest spread like a symmetrical
symmetrical trophy his navel pulsating
his hirsute thighs dripping with bright
droplets his tight wet black bathing
trunks bloated and bursting with vigor
where his great fat bully bag was pulled
up and back like a padded shield over
his revealed beast hood a husband to can
on occasion find his wife a little
wearing particularly as she is a self
constructed simulacrum of the perfect
American homemaker and even more
particularly if he is planning to drug
and rape her twelve-year-old child
Humbert married his first wife Illyria
the brainless babba as quote a piteous
compromise unquote what attracted him
was the imitation she gave the little
girl he marries Charlotte out of the
coldest expediency and what follows in
these implacably talented early pages is
a vicious parity parody of marital cheer
Charlotte beautifies the love nest and
pours over your home is you while
Humbert handsomely glass and gloats with
quote a cesspool of rotting
monsters behind his Slovak boyish smile
unquote with his feelings quite
unengaged Humbert is free to celebrate
the course pink skin of her neck or the
way the wings of her nose shine coat
having shared or burnt up their ration
of powder unquote or the grow tasteless
reveries unquote in which she predicts
that the soul of the child she lost
another dead child would return quote in
the form of the child she would bear in
her present wedlock unquote with Valyria
Humbert managed to perform sexually by
having her dress up in a girl's plain
nightshirt quote I derived some fun from
that nuptial night and had the idiot in
hysterics by Sunrise
and occurred with Charlotte he relies on
good liquor two or three kinds of
vitamins and the richest foods available
and also contrives to engage in the
litres bedroom where he experiences
quote some initial trouble for which
however he amply compensates her by a
fantastic display of old-world indians
thereafter in the fifty days of their
cohabitation it is genetic consonants
that alone sustains him quote so I Tom
peeped across the hedges of years into
one little windows and when by means of
the pitifully ardent naively lascivious
caresses she the noble nipple and
massive thigh prepared me for the
performance of my Knightly duty it was
still a nymphet said that in despair I
try to pick up as I bathe through the
undergrowth of dark decaying forests
even by locally
prevailing standards Charlotte is
egregiously traduced in Lolita poor
Charlotte rigid religious snobbish and
formidable
an exponent of the fake candor that
eternally precludes the real thing the
novel kills are off of course yet she
survives as a cat as a character and her
resilience is the resilience of young
America NATO cough is scoffed at the
notion but the descent of Humbert
Humbert a boho among [ __ ]
with his intricate ironies and lusts on
the fru-u-- there of America is in some
sense a pitifully AK visitation like
Lolita America is above all young quote
with a quality of wide-eyed unsung
innocent surrender that my lacquered toy
bright toy bright swiss villages and
exhaustively lauded out alps no longer
possess unquote with unsurpassed
sharpness of idea
Nabokov captures the rhythms of the
American Road but for Humbert the circum
ambient wilds represent the humiliation
and again a travesty their openness and
freedom or continual reproach to his own
furtiveness and ignoble constraint
admire this supreme modulation in which
the swiftness of disdain gradually slows
in the heavier water of anxiety quote
nuclear noon the various types of motor
court are operators the reformed
criminal the retired teacher and the
business flop among the males and the
motherly pseudo ladylike and medomak
variants among the females and sometimes
trains would cry in the monstrously hot
and humid night with heart-rending an
ominous tangency mingling power and
hysteria in one desperate scream well
here where Humbert allows himself the
dejected clarity of hindsight quote and
so we roll east we had been everywhere
we had really seen nothing and I catch
myself thinking today that our long
journey had only defiled with a sinuous
trail of slime the lovely trustful
dreamy enormous country that by then in
retrospect was no more to us than a
collection of dogged maps ruined tour
books old tires and her Psalms in the
night every night every night
the moment I feigned sleep it has often
been suggested that the morality of
Lolita is not inherent that something
tacked on at the end like the last scene
of Hitchcock's Psycho in which a swarthy
psychiatrist is produced to explain in
neat jargon the very different
depravities in a very different mode
as if after a 260 page debauch the
author sobered up gave his phallus a
brisk downward chop with the side of his
hand and started tricking out his de
Newman with a few face-saving
spiritual mottos Humbert on the hillside
begging forgiveness of Aleta and the
American landscape Humbert paying his
last call on the plane of pregnant mrs.
Richard F Schiller Humberts last
memories of Lolita as the Auden entirely
ordinary little girl she kept on being
throughout everything these scenes are
justly famous and even the dissenting
critic will a lot on a certain emotional
par but we are not moved by artful
editorials we are moved by the ending of
Lolita by its finality and justice
because perhaps only subliminally we
have seen it coming even today after two
lalita's lifespans people are still
wandering up to Dmitry Novikov and ask
him what it was like having a dirty old
man for a father even sophisticated
readers still think that Nabokov had
something to feel guilty about great
novels are shocking and then then after
the shock dies down you get aftershocks
the presiding image of Lolita so often
missed by the first-time reader I know I
missed it years ago is adumbrated in its
forward Lolita in childbed dead with her
dead daughter let's see what forms and
colorations not a cough gives to this
stark sit silhouette in Paris when
Humbert is confining himself to visiting
prostitutes whose mere youth warranted
his catching some appalling disease he
contacts a specialist who arranges such
things and the next day an asthmatic
woman coarsely painted garrulous garlicy
with an almost farcical Provencal accent
and a black mustache above a purple lip
took me to what was apparently her own
Donna sale and there after explosively
kissing the bunch tips of her fat
fingers she theatrically drew aside a
curtain to reveal what I judged was that
part of the rumor a large a nun
fastidious family usually slept
it was now empty safe from monstrously
plump sallow repulsively plain girl at
least fifteen with red ribbon thick
black braids who sat on a chair
perfunctorily nursing a bald doll those
last five words maybe swamped by the
bounty of their predecessors but they
exactly answer to get the dreadful
grimace of clenched teeth tenderness
unquote which on the previous page
Humbert sees in an accusing mirror while
dallying with another small [ __ ] in
another small Eden such the Travis
travesty is a familial feeling among
quote very young harlots disguised as
children unquote images of deformity of
half aliveness of cruel displacements in
mortal time give Lolita aglow no less
none and waxy than its heroines corpse
for the novel is shot through with these
bald dolls and wizened mannequins with
the old nod young and the young maid old
on the eve of the seduction the lethal
delectation Humbert writes I should have
known by the signs made to be by
something in the liter the real child
Lolita or some Haggard angel behind her
back
that nothing but pain and horror would
result from the expected rapture the
next morning as he prepares to leave the
hotel quote I was forced to devote a
dangerous amount of time to rearranging
the bed in such a racist suggest the
abandoned nest of a restless father and
his tomboy daughter instead of an
ex-convict Saturnalia with a couple of
fat old [ __ ] then I finished dressing
and had the Horry bellboy come up for
the bags for rebelled boy on the HOA ry
on the next page Lolita is both quote
immortal demon disguised as a female
child and quote the small ghost of
somebody had just killed unquote in
death Charlotte is a doll
a doll like we Korea girl diagram 't
eyes this is very American by the man
who ran her over
shopping for low on his way to camp to
claim her Humbert is surrounded by quote
life-sized plastic figures of snot-nosed
children with done colored greenish
brown dotted furnish faces unquote
these figures reappear mutilated in a
latest storefront just before Lolita
finally takes off wig 'less and armless
on the floor the lair Custer of three
slender arms and a blonde wig two of the
arms happen to be twisted and seemed to
suggest a clasping gesture of horror and
supplication all these hideous fragments
will be hideously jumbled under an out
weight of pain in the dreams Humbert has
when lo is gone quote she did haunt my
sleep but she appeared there in strange
and ludicrous disguises as Valyria or
Charlotte or a crop or cross between
them that complex ghost would come to me
shedding shift after shift in an
atmosphere of great manically and
disgust and would recline in dull
invitation on some narrow board or hard
City with flesh ajar like a like the
rubber valve of a soccer balls bladder I
would find myself dentures fractured or
hopelessly mislaid in horrible shaumbra
garni where i would be entertained
tedious vivisect there's the visiting
parties that generally ended with
Charlotte or Valyria weeping in my
bleeding arms and being tenderly kissed
by my brother Lee lips in a dream
disorder of auctioneer Viennese
bric-a-brac pity impotence and the brown
wigs tragic Oh women who had just been
gassed in his afterward not a cough
explains the first quote shiver a Lolita
was inspired by a newspaper story about
an ape quote who after months of coaxing
by a scientist produced the first
drawing ever charcoal by an animal the
sketch showed the bars of the poor
creatures cage unquote inspiration
needn't be very opposite but the app
isn't opposite
as of this first little throb has
perhaps being miss emphasized it's not
so much that Lolita has been encaged and
enslaved though she has been Humberts
crime is to force her out of nature to
force a child through the hoops of
womanhood insulting and degrading her
childish essence Nabokov says that the
initial impulse have quote no textual
connection unquote with the fiction that
followed but in fact there are at least
a couple of backward glances Valyria
soon to die in childbirth spend some of
her last days imitating an animal on a
diet of bananas and dates as part of a
paid ethnological experiment and on his
travels Humbert visits a zoo where quote
a large troop of monkeys lived on a
concrete replica of Christopher
Columbus's flagship and the spend their
lives mutely symbolizing America Lolita
is trained I pampered and terrorized she
subsists on apples and sugar lumps given
in exchange for the animal repertoire
only once as she specifically imagined
in this way it was one of those moments
an extraordinary expansion where Natick
off nav across pro streaks off like a
tracer bullet in a dark sky the sexual
act has taken place on a hilltop quote I
remember that the operation was over all
over and she was weeping in my arms a
sanitary storm sobs after one of the
fits of moodiness that had become so
frequent with her in the course of that
otherwise admirable year and so we lay
with one of those joke and so we lay
when with one of those jokes that have
ended by knocking my poor heart out of
its groove I met the unblinking dark
eyes of two strange and beautiful
children followed by a stout lady with
Raven with a raven black bob who
automatically added a while really to
bouquet while staring over her shoulder
at us from behind her lovely carved blue
stone children with the quiet murmured
order one gives a sweat stain distracted
cringing trained animal even in the
worst of plaits what mad hope or hate
makes the young beasts
flanks palsied what black stars pierced
the heart of the trainer I made lo get
up and we decorously walked and then in
decorously scuttled down to the car and
with a scrunch and a skid we drove off
lo still struggling with her clothes and
swearing at me in a language that I
never dream little girls could no let
alone use shockable Humbert who finds
bad language circuit disgusting I
shudder to think how his ghost the tired
in its ghostly smoking jacket would
round on me for calling him a Bulgarian
and a Philistine actually he is more of
a more dangerous and rarer breed such
people because they cannot make art out
of life make their lives into art
Humbert is the artist mark a to see the
magic of nymphets he says you have to be
an artist and a madman oh how you have
to cringe and hide wrangling yet more
powerful sleeping pills from the family
doctor on which to gorge the limb vet he
comes away with violet blue capsules
quote intended not for neurotics whom a
glass of water would calm but only for
great sleepless artists who had to have
to die for a few hours in order to live
for centuries the weeping Humbert
sheds above-average tears hot opalescent
thick tears the poets and lovers shared
he is her quote Catullus
he is poor Catullus quote the gentle and
dreamy regions through which I crept
with the patrimony --hz poets not crime
stamping ground this is all blasphemous
flannel naturally hoobat hum could refer
to the gauged postponement of his orgasm
as quote a nicety physiological
equipoise comparable to certain
techniques in the arts
quote emphatically no killers that we
Humbert peds poets never kill but this
one does before he pulls the trigger he
recites the poem a parody under the
circumstances a travesty of Ash
Wednesday an attic often never had much
time for Elliot used to call The Waste
Land the waistline necessarily on
censorious himself a neighbor is quote a
retired executioner or writer the
religious tracts who cared humbert
humbert all his life has long for great
disasters explosions earthquakes
situations where quote nothing really
mattered where nothing mattered anymore
and everything was allowed quote the
shipwreck and at all alone with the
drowned passengers shivering child
darling this is only a game in art in a
sense nothing really matters no one gets
hurt it is only a game but an artistic
reckoning must be completed and in
Natick off art itself provide provides
the reproach and the punishment his mark
a figures pay a deep the steep price for
their presumption for their monkeying
around with the order of things
our bi'ness in laughter in the dark with
his plan to cartoon afire the old
masters Kinbote impale fire with his
epic and vandal ously solipsistic miss
reading of john shades poem Herman
Herman another artist in despair with
his doomed crime and his doomed novel in
as much as the Lita is Humberts creation
Lolita the novel then he is partly
redeemed leaving us this book which has
quote bits of Mara sticking to it and
blood and beautiful bright green flies
unquote those flies we think rather of
their quote horribly experienced unquote
brethren zigzagging over the sticky
sugar pour in some fowl diner in some
dismal ex Prairie State not all the book
comes from Humberts pen he isn't
responsible
for the forward where we learn of the
leaders death in childbed Humbert sin is
biological or sin against the ordinary
he has made ordinary biology impossible
marriage child birth a daughter ordinary
happiness ordinary health in grey star a
settlement in the remotest northwest and
quote the capital town of the book
unquote as Natick often nodes it may or
not surprise Humbert to learn the what
he has written is not a love story but a
travesty what makes human beings laughs
not just gaiety or irony the laughter
vanishes seriousness is a misconception
often made by the humanists and by that
far greater multitude the heart of
laughing the humorously impaired or
under gifted human beings laugh if you
notice to express relief exasperation
stoicism hysteria embarrassment disgust
and cruelty Lolita is perhaps the
funniest novel in the language because
it allows laughter its full complexity
and range we hear its characteristic
edge when Humbert uses his quote pet
unquote to the play of his wit and his
prose this is the laughter we hear not
too often I hope when we recognize the
outright perfection of our moral sword
or sordid is a word largely conspicuous
by its absence in Humberts tale it's one
self-directed appearance I think comes
in brackets the enchanted hunters when
he concedes that the sleeping pill
business is quote a rather sordid affair
Entre Nous rd unquote the mock genteel
French tag is an important constituent
of Humberts corrosive mask and there's
there there is a feeling of all laughter
spent when reluctantly admiring the
shapely hands of Richard F Schiller mr.
Lowe Humbert writes
I have heard too much too many bodies
with my twisted poor hands
to be proud of them French epithets a
Dorsett a Dorsett yokels knuckles and
Austrian tailors flat fingertips
that's Humbert Humbert at one point
comparing himself to Joyce Novikov said
my English is Pat ball to his champion
game at another he tabulated the
rambling rumbles Don quick suit as a
tennis match the Don taking it in for
hard sets and we all remember Lolita on
the court her form quote excellent -
superb unquote
but her grace so sterile according to
Humbert quote that she could not even
win from panting me and my old fashioned
lifting drive unquote now although of
course Joyce and Nabokov never met in
competition it seems to me that Nabokov
was the more complete player
Joyce seemed to be cruising about on all
surfaces at once and maddening
maddeningly indulged his trick shots on
high pressure points his drop smash his
sight spun half volley log Nava cough
just went out there and did the business
all liveness power and touch losing
early in the French say Joyce would be
off playing exhibitions in Casablanca
with various arthritic legends and
working on his inside out between the
legs forehand dink
whereas Nabokov and his entourage would
quit the rusty dust a roland garros for
summer like hull or nail see to prepare
for Wimbledon on our spurned and sodden
grass we still talk about Joyce in the
villa in the pavilion constantly the
footwork the flow the dream backhand the
maybes the might of beans
the tiny one the Italian with his left
hand shackled to his right leg
then we move on to the great Russian and
the ice trays to the honors board and
that across fat wedge of Grand Slams
when they come across something wise or
witty or fond or funny or something
obviously necessary to the whole warmed
readers make a little vertical mark on
the page with their book side pencils
accordingly then the perfect novel would
have perfect verticals running down the
length of every margin it never works
out quite like that because the novel is
a tangled thing and shifts its shape
over the years I have read Lolita eight
or nine times and not always in the same
edition but the margins of my staple
hardback they're a pompeiian litter of
ticks queries exclamation marks and
lines straight and squiggly and doubled
and tripled my pencil comments I realize
former kind of surrealistic summary of
the whole but you can't steady insult
ear disguise playing with Dostoevsky
love proceeds very very good traveling I
won pup and at least three important
dogs vampire again Oh flu co-ed the bike
poor poor dolly brimming quite mad now
alone sobbing over sneaker all along all
dead horribly experienced clearly these
are not as scholars notes and they and
they move towards no edifice of
understanding or completion there gasps
of continually renewed surprise I expect
to read the novel many more times and
I'm running out of clean white space
thank you very much
well I think we have about 12 minutes of
question-and-answer if any way anyone
would like to
madam yes could you please explain the
significance of Humbert Humberts name
and why it's repeated twice um I don't
know if I can't explain the significance
of it and he did say something about it
being horribly ugly and of course a
reflection of itself just as Herman
Haman in despair I don't have so there
are some scholars in the audience who
can enlighten us but I didn't think it's
anything other than than a kind of
brutish mirror effect that he was after
with the name
sorry
well I think we've all seen the Kubrick
film with the six-foot Lolita of Sue
Lyons and the excellent performance of
James Mason as Humbert Shelley Winters
in that in that film is its kind of not
bad as Charlotte but but not formidable
enough to - hysterical - dismissible
Charlotte should be frightening but the
real fault of the film I think is is
Peter Sellers as quilty where he does
his sort of German psychiatrist number
and all the rest of it and you think you
think with fury and exasperation of all
the great things in the novel that that
have been you know there isn't time to
do and instead we get Peter Sellers
doing irrelevant comic turns and as he
is he is very unwisely indulged by the
director I think in that film
I've been enhanced by the
influenced by to determine when I wrote
money I don't know I think no because it
is a very dangerous model for young
writers and and and very tempting
because one one there's something about
that disdainful Swift superior voice
that is that is very appealing and I I
messed around with it most notably in my
novel success which was bit earlier than
money I think in money I was being more
influenced by Saul Bellow so I was
moving on to something I thought a
little bit more robust but but his
phrases and his rhythms are very
seductive and you know you still have to
to fight against them the trouble with
that voice is that only geniuses need
apply
really and any anything less than full
genius and you begin to look ridiculous
so
sir
well you're opposed to pedophilia then
that is why it isn't being shown here
and it's one is astonished that it was
ever made because the the the law is
very is very clear and very full it says
that no pedophilia act or anything that
looks like a pedophilia Act can be shown
in the movies and that's that isn't it I
mean you can get a six-year-old body
double to play Lolita but it's still
meant to look like a pedophilia Act and
there's an end in several European
countries and I've I've read various
things about it and I know that I've
read for instance that Dmitry Novikov
delighted me a son and a highly gifted
and accomplished translation translator
of his father's work and others thinks
it's a masterpiece and I think the
writer Steven Schiff has said I mean
Adrian lines track record is not that
encouraging as a dangerous indecent
proposal or fatal attraction but shift
said that he'd made a kind of huge leap
and I've read interviews with Adrian
line where he seemed to me to know what
he was talking about and he knew what
the crucial parts of the novel were and
it's quite possible that it is you know
a brilliant and moral piece of work I
somehow somehow doubt it because well
only because the novel is in ER and the
movie the movies are out and this is a
deeply internal novel and it's only it's
only through this tremendous network of
imagery that that that we actually find
out how Nabokov was was working at as a
as a moral immoral diagram
like I can't see a movie reproducing
that on screen but we may be wrong I
think the movie should certainly be
shown there's no evidence that the
illegal behavior on film encourages
illegal behavior in life and wouldn't it
be good to have something where we can
air our feelings again about this and
see where we stand because the revulsion
against pedophilia is is you know no
parent is free of it and it but it does
lead very quickly to a kind of vigilante
spirit and it's a very difficult area
and this would be this would be a useful
forum to have the film before us and to
discuss it and see how we feel about it
we are adults after all even if the
leader is not um there's a mysterious
triangular relationship I noticed
between Nabokov Humbert and quilting you
think perhaps you could explain a little
bit about them um but I did say that
quilty is a is is humbles equivalent in
many ways but he's he's a more liberated
type of pedophile than Humbert but but
they are meant to be equivalent figures
and they have exactly the same fancy
prose style of a murderer and and
physically resemble each other and they
just the difference is that that that
Humbert did love Lolita and Lolita
findeth loved quilty and that's that's
how it's balanced
one more question bats and he also falls
Lolita has a lot of different name she's
dialing you know there seems to be these
kind of different
there's there's always a significance in
in everything in in Natick off people
ask me about my names and why do i my
characters have such weird names the
answer is that it these this this name
is going to appear a lot in this book
you know it is a no word should be
wasted in a novel and a name is a word
and you're going to see be seeing a lot
of it and so there is constant play on
on naming in fact I think that the the
extravagance with which uh novelist
names his characters gives a a good
index to his reality level to his the
extent that he is playful with life and
with words if I begin a novel where
everyone's called Tom net field and John
Pierson and David Archer I somehow think
I'm not going to stay with it very long
and and and you know look at Saul
Bellow's names and Dickens his name's ko
Obon mark and Rinaldo can table then you
know you're in for something livelier
well thanks very much for coming thank
you